hello this is the fourth and final
lecture in the proof complexity talks
for the satisfiability boot camp
in this talk we're going to discuss
cutting planes and then
the cleat coloring principle and craig
interpolation for
obtaining lower bounds to cutting
plane's degree
we'll then cover norshtallinzos and the
polynomial calculus these are
polynomial based proof systems and
finally we'll cover automatizability
as a separate topic mostly our treatment
of these
topics are pretty cursory uh they give
us the basic definitions a few of the
initial results
and just enough does not cover however
the current state of the art in these
areas especially
the cutting planes and north stalin's
lots and
polynomial calculus portions so let's
start with cutting planes
cutting planes is a propositional proof
system
based on reasoning with linear
integer inequalities or integer
programming
the classic work on this is done in the
60s and 70s
cook collard and tehran proposed it as a
propositional proof system in 1987.
variables are x1 x2 x3 etc these are
0 1 valued variables where interpreting
0 is false and 1 is true since they're
essentially boolean
values but interpreted as integers
lines in the cutting planes proof are
linear inequalities with integer
coefficients
shown here as a1 x1 plus a2 x2 plus dot
dot dot
a and xn greater than equal to a0 and
again the ai's are all
integers but possibly negative integers
clauses become in in inequalities
so if we're trying to refute a set of
clauses we transform them first to
inequalities so the clause
x or y or z becomes x plus y plus z
greater than or equal to one and these
express the same
condition given that we're interpreting
zero is false and one is true
likewise x or not y or z
becomes x minus y plus z greater than or
equal to zero
the idea here is we think of
not y as being the same as one minus y
so we get x
plus one minus y plus z greater than
equal to one which is the same as x
minus y plus c greater than or equal to
zero
uh cutting planes like resolution is a
refutation system
the we start off with two types of
initial axioms
and then hypotheses and the hypotheses
are linear inequalities and we're trying
to refute
that they all hold it once with integer
solutions especially zero one valued
solutions
so the logical axioms are x i greater
than equal to zero
and not x i greater than or equal to
minus one and this reflex that
reflects the fact that each x i has
value either zero or one so it's bounded
between zero and one
additional inferences are the addition
rule
and the division rule the addition rule
takes its hypotheses two linear
inequalities
and just directly sums them up together
so it
clearly the conclusion follows from
hypotheses the division rule
is as follows we take an integer c
greater than 0
and we assume that c is a divisor of
a 1 through a n so it's divisor of the
coefficients on the left-hand side
of the equation and then from
the sum of a i xi greater than or equal
to a0 we can infer the sum
of a i over c times x i greater than
equal to
a0 over c rounded up to the nearest
integer
so on the left hand side the
coefficients a i over c are integers
because of the hypothesis that c is a
divisor of a i
on the right hand side a 0 over c may be
fractional
but it gets rounded up to the nearest
integer
and this is a valid inference because
the coefficients are all integers a i
over c's are all integers
x i's are all integers either 0 1. and
so
the left hand side is an integer and so
if it's greater than or equal to a zero
over c it's also greater than or equal
to a z over c
rounded up to the nearest integer
and then we're trying to do a refutation
we're supposed to end up with a false
linear inequality at the end
and the final line should be zero
greater than or equal to one
and we can always get any inequality
zero greater than a positive number in
this form by using the division rule
so as an example of how this works
suppose gamma contains
the three clauses not x or not y not x
or not z and also not y or not z
this expresses intuitively that no two
of x y and z
are true and we'd like to re-express
this using cutting planes in
inferences so first of all these three
clauses turn into
inequalities the first one's minus x
minus y greater than equal to minus one
in other words because one minus x plus
one minus y
is greater than or equal to one we get
the first inequality
and similarly the second one is minus x
minus z greater than equal to minus one
and the third one is minus y minus c is
greater than equal to minus 1.
if we add up using two instances of the
addition rule these things we get
minus 2 times x plus minus 2 times y
plus minus 2 times e greater than equal
to minus 3.
now we can divide by two and we get
minus
x minus y minus c greater than equal to
minus one
and this of course means intuitively the
same thing as x plus y plus z
less than or equal to one now you can't
write this ladder inequality you know
cutting planes
proof you have to use it in the form
with the minus signs but nonetheless
this is a more succinct way of
expressing that no two of
x y and z are true and you'll notice we
could not have derived this without
using
the division rule with its rounding
properties
so a nice
but simple theorem is that cutting
planes has polynomial size refutations
of the well the clause is expressing the
negation of the pigeon principle
so let's just um reformulate this
as um in inequalities the totality axiom
says the summation over j
of x i j is greater than or equal to one
um injectivity axiom says the summation
over i
of x i j is less than or equal to one
so you can derive these things um
similar to the argument on the previous
slide so now we get
the summation over all variables x i j
is greater than
n plus one and also the summation of all
x i j's is less than equal to
than n what i mean by that is negating
both sides of that so the
sum of the negative the x i j is greater
than or equal to minus n
and then we add those two things
together to conclude
that zero is greater than or equal to
one
so that's a nice simple proof and
cutting planes is ideally suited to do
it because it can just directly sum
things up
hence as a corollary resolution does not
piece simulate cutting planes
and also by the comments side comments
earlier constant depth fragrance proof
systems do not piece emulate cutting
planes
again by the pigeon principle
on the other hand we can go the other
way to a certain extent
cutting planes does piece simulate
resolution
and the idea for the proof there is that
a single resolution step can be
easily simulated by using an addition
rule and then a division by two rule
actually perhaps using several addition
rules to round things up to two and then
and then a division by two rule um
and on the other hand as shown by gert
that cutting planes is p
simulated by fragaproof systems and the
idea for this theorem is that you can
use this carry save addition
of the type we used earlier for summing
vectors of integers for the pigeon
principle proof
to express with polynomial size
propositional formulas in a fragra proof
system the
inequalities given by lines in a cutting
plane's
refutation and thus it becomes
once this is done it's then fairly
straightforward to simulate cutting
planes
by fraga proofs
on the other hand for lower bound foot
lock showed that for cutting planes
you do have exponential size proofs
for the clique coloring clauses
to talk about this we first need to
define the cleat coloring clauses
so the cleat coloring clauses are a set
of unsatisfiable set of clauses
which are unsatisfiable by virtue of a
graph on
and vertices not being able to have both
a clique of size
m and a coloring of size m minus one so
a clique of size
m says there's m vertices which
are all adjacent pairwise to each other
and a coloring of size m minus one says
there's an assignment of
m minus one distinct colors to all the
vertices
such that no two adjacent vertices get
the same color
so you can't have both of these because
there would be no way to color
the vertices inside the clique of size m
so we're going to use variables p q
and r attached with subscripts the
subscripts will be a
c and i and j and
a will range over m the size
of the clique c will range over m minus
1
the number of colors and i and j will
range over vertices in the graph
so for each n we get a distinct
instance of the coloring clauses so
the meaning of the variables p a i is
that
vertex i is the eighth member of the
clique
the variables q i c are intended to say
that
vertex i has color c
the variables r i j i tended to say
there's an edge joining the vertices i
and j and now we have clauses
a expressing the existence of a clique
and
clauses b expressing the existence of a
coloring
so the clauses a involve only the
variables p
and r they don't need the coloring at
all uh the first
types of clauses in them are the or over
i of p
a i for this is for a fixed
and this says that i there's some i such
as i is the eighth vertex
of the clique and then the next
clauses in apr are not
p a i or p a prime
or not p a prime i uh which says that
it's
not the case that i is both the eighth
member of the clique
and the a prime member of a clique
and the third types of clauses are not p
a i or not p a prime j
or r i j and this says that if
i is the eighth member of the clique and
j is the a prime member of the clique a
is not equal to a prime
then there's an edge that's rij from
vertex i
to vertex j so
with these clauses are satisfied by
assign some assignment
then we have a clique of size m the
clauses bqr
express the coloring and the first one
is or over c of qic
which for a fixed eye this says that
vertex i is assigned some color c
and the next set of clauses are not q i
c
or not q i c prime which says that each
vertex
is assigned at most one color and the
third clauses are not q
i c or not q j c
or not r i j
which this says that if if both vertices
i
and j are signed color c then there's no
edge
between r between i and j
so one thing to notice here is that the
r
variables appear only positive in the
clauses apr
that is unnegated and they occur only
negatively that is negated
in the clauses bqr and that will be
important
very shortly
so cry check
showed that any resolution refutation of
the cleat coloring tattoology
for m equal to the square root of n
requires exponential size
in this case two to the omega end of the
three quarters
and shortly after that pudlock showed
that cutting planes
likewise requires exponential size
proofs really
refutations in both cases for the cleat
coloring clauses
the two proofs have a similar strategy
they both use a craig interpolation
theorem which i'll describe
on the next slide what that means and
they use these
known lore exponential bounds on the
size of monotone
circuits that distinct that
distinguished graphs with large cliques
and graphs with large
colorings for cutting planes the second
theorem
it was required to extend these bounds
for boolean circuits to real circuits
and i'll describe that
in a little bit later but first let's
talk about
craig interpolation
so craig interpolation refers to
a classic result even in first order
logic of
defining interpolants and this craig
interpolation now
in this setting is the the
simplification of this down to
propositional logic um so this work was
done
by the two papers already mentioned in
cryo check and put lock and earlier
the first work along these lines was
beau net potassium bras
and then raspurov as well did the full
version of it
so let's make the
definition we have two formulas a
involving variables p and r and b
involving
vary variables q and r and we assume
that
the conjunction a and b is unsatisfiable
and we assume the only common variables
in a and b
are the indicated variables are so craig
interpolant
for a and b it's a predicate
c of r that is involving only the common
variables r
such that for any setting of to the
variables
r and p and q if c of r is false
then a of p r is false in other words
for any setting the variables are if c
of r is false
then a of p r is unsatisfiable
and then conversely for any setting that
variables
are if c of r is true then b of q r is
unsatisfiable
and another way to say this is in terms
of implication which is how
craig initially stated in interpolation
we have because a and b is unsatisfiable
that means that a implies not b
so these conditions on c means that
a implies c that's from not c
implies a and then c implies not b
so what we're getting here is if a
implies b we can
interpolate or stick in the middle a c
and the c
only depends on the common variables the
variables are
that occur both in a and b
and the theorem is that whenever a of pr
and b of qr is unsatisfiable there is a
craig interpolant c of r and one easy
way to take this is we can take
c of r to be exists p a of p r
or for all q not b of q r
and it's easy to check that that is a
boolean function
that defines an interpolant
the problem here is we've got
existential quantification
so we may not have a polynomial time
interpolant for instance or some
feasibly computable interpolant
in the general case and there's a lot of
open questions here of course
and but in some cases we do manage to
get polynomial time
craig interpolants and this happens in
particular
when we have a resolution refutation of
the set of clauses
a of p r union b of q r
so the theorem is that we make some we
assume that
the conjunction or the set of clauses a
of p r b of q
r has a resolution refutation of size m
and then we
further assume that all the variables r
either appear
only positively in the clauses of a of
pr or
only negatively in the clauses b of q
are
with if all these conditions hold then
there's a craig interpolant which is
computed by
monotone boolean circuit of size order
m so monotone boolean circuit means the
following the inputs of the variables
are
and they're not negated because it's
because it's monotone
and the gates in the circuit are just
ands and ors
and the total number of gates is order m
and m is the
number of steps in the resolution
refutation so as an application
the cleat coloring principles require
exponential size resolution refutations
as we'll discuss on the next couple
slides
so here's a sketch of the proof of the
craig interpolation theorem
basically the resolution reputation r
transforms directly
into the desired monotone circuit
we take each clause in the refutation so
view the reputation as a dag
and we're going to take that dag
structure and faithfully transform it
into
a monotone circuit so what we're going
to do
is define and for each clause c
appearing in the proof we're going to
define we're going to have a gate
g of c and g of c
is going to have the property that
for any assignment of variables you
could look at the bottom of the screen
here
for any assignment of variables to
and any partial assignment that
falsifies
all the literals in clause c if g sub c
is false then there's some clause of
a that is false and if g sub c is true
then there's some clause in b that's
false so g
sub c is like a pointer that says
assuming c is false
then g of c will either say something in
a is false
or we'll say something in b is false and
we now just go inductively through
the the resolution refutation
and construct a circuit so we start off
with
um initial clauses from a of pr
we can just take g of c equal to false
because
here it's trivially an interpolant
because g of c is false and we're saying
that
we're assuming that any partial
assignment falsif that falsifies
a that the an a clause must false by
some acons
and some way for a b clause initial
clause g of c is true
because if that clause is falsified then
there's some b clauses falsified
and then for without going into too many
details
if we have if we resolve on a variable p
that's one of the variables that occurs
in
a but not in b we replace
that resolution inference by an or gate
so
the g sub c d the conclusion of the
resolution inference
is just the or of the g sub p i's and
the g sub d
p i bars which are the values for the
hypotheses of the
resolution inference something dual
works for
resolving on the variables q that are
pure and b
but not a we just replace that inference
by an and gate
and then if we resolve on a variable r
uh it's a little more complex here we we
either use
g sub c d like g for the conclusion of
the
resolution inference it's either r or g
sub cri
and g sub dri or it's something dual g
sub cri
or ri and g sub dri
and the point is that if r
is monotone and a appears only
positively in a or monotone and b by
appearing only negatively in b
we can choose one of these or the others
and still
maintain the interpolation property
so i'll let you work that out on your
own i'm not going to try to go through
all the details here but the important
point here is that the
monotone circuit defining a craig
interpolation
craig interpolant is just read directly
off of the resolution refutation
and now we get the
theorem that i already mentioned for res
for resolution so that any resolution
refutation of the
coloring topology for m equals m one
half requires size two to the omega
n to the three fourths so we just apply
the craig interpolation theorem to the
cleat coloring tautology
assuming that there's a short resolution
refutation for the click color
intentology
so the variables are encode the edges of
a graph
um if the craig interpolation property
tells us there's a
there's a that if there's a short
resolution reputation
of size s we get an interpolant and if
the interpolant's false it means that
a of pr is unsatisfiable in other words
the g does not have a clique of size
m if c of r is true then b of q
r is unsatisfiable in other words g does
not have a coloring of size n minus
one but
on the other hand we know from results
of rasbora have been strengthened by
a lone papa that any monotone boolean
circuit that
distinguishes between graphs with large
cliques and graphs large colorings
must have exponential size so it follows
immediately then that the resolution
refutation
must have exponential size
and that's a sketch of that proof
and the general framework of the proof
for cutting planes is similar
so woodlock extended the craig
interpolation theorem to
cutting planes here again we assume that
the set of clauses
apr and bqr have a cutting plane's
refutation of
m steps and that the variables are
appear only positively in the clauses
apr
or only negatively in the clauses bqr
the conclusion is there's a craig
interpolant
which is computed by a monotone real
circuit not a boolean search anymore a
real circuit of size
m to the order one and a real circuit
means a circuit where the values
are on the wires in the circuit are real
numbers
uh the circuit has arbitrary unary
and binary gates that take as inputs
real numbers and output a real number
but must compute monotone real functions
a monotone real function means that if
you increase the value of one of the
inputs
you cannot decrease the value of the
output
and then the raspberry pi lower balance
the proof can be reworked to show the
same type of lower bounds
for real monotone circuits and then as a
corollary
to the interpolation for
clean coloring as a correlate to the
interpolation for cutting planes
and the lower bounds on real monotone
circuits
for separating uh
graphs with large cliques from peaks of
size down from
graphs with colorings of size n minus
one we get the cutting planes does not
have polynomial size refutations in fact
it needs exponential refuge size
refutations for the clique coloring
clauses
expressing that a graph is both
k-colorable and has a k plus one clique
for appropriate values of k
so now we're going to shift gears a
little bit and talk about two algebraic
proof systems
first one is the norstellenz proof
system
this was introduced by beam and pogba
also cryochecked potassium pudlock
we work generally over finite field
characteristic p
variables x1 x2 or 01 valued and now
the lines in the proof are polynomials
so
a polynomial f is identified with the
assertion that
f equals 0. and
we refute a set of initial polynomials
f j by giving polynomials
gj and h such that the following
equality is a valid polynomial
equality so we have that
the initial polynomials f i times g
f of the sum over j of fj times gj
plus the sum over x i squared minus x
i times h i is equal to one
and this equality so the values
x i take on value zero one so for such
for x i equal to zero one we certainly
have
x i squared minus x i equals 0. and
if this equality holds there's no way to
set the values
of x1 x2 x3 etc so that the fjs are all
simultaneously equal to because if there
were such a way
then the left hand side would just be
identically would be equal to zero for
those settings to the variables
x i and the right hand side of course
would be one
so what we're getting here is a null
stellenz refutation as a kind of
static proof you write out just a single
equality
and if this equality holds there's no
way to simultaneously set all the
input polynomials the fjs to zero
so it serves as a refutation to the
assertion that the fjs are all equal to
zero at once
so we can translate clauses
into polynomials and then
noel stellenzance is known not to
simulate resolution it becomes a proof
system
but the converse is true as well
resolution or even constant fragus
systems do not simulate
sheldon's odds um so for this it's
traditional
to work with the degree of north
shelton's lots of proofs rather than
their size
it's just easier and more natural in
many ways to work with the
with the degree and in general we're
going to work over a field of finite
characteristic p
and a couple sample classic lower bounds
here
on degree is that for there's these
counting mod q principles where q is not
a power of p
and uh
there are not constant degree nor
stellenzos
reputations of the accounting mod q
principles uh
in this case and this is due to uh beam
and pagliatzo cryocheck
potassium pudlog
and stronger result then is
linear lower bounds on the degree for
the pigeon principles
and this is due the first lower balance
substantial amount amounts given by
being quick edmunds and plotting the
outside potassity and the strong linear
lower bounds given by
raspberrov so we have very nice degree
lower bounds on north stalin's lots as
well as we can get size lower bounds
i don't want to say too much more about
this except to say that there's lots of
applications to nordstell and zots lower
bounds
this includes separation results for
constant depth figure proofs this was
the initial reason for
uh developing north stalin's lots
actually especially
um and also
separations for subclasses of tfmp
the total np functions uh more recently
it's they've been used to no shelters
lower bounds have been used to get lower
bounds for monotone span programs and
also to get lower bounds for cutting
planes refutations via lifting theorems
another related proof system is the
polynomial calculus
the polynomial calculus has the same
type of syntax
as the norstelenzotz system but it's a
so-called dynamic system rather than a
static proof system
it starts with hypotheses and then it
combines them with
addition and multiplication so think of
the hypothesis
f on the in this inference on the right
meaning f equals zero and the conclusion
f times g
meaning f times g equals zero and
hypotheses
f and g on the left-hand side are f
equals zero and g equals zero and the
inclusion is f plus g
equals zero and a polynomial calculus
refutation of a set of polynomials
it's a derivation of the polynomial one
starting with the f js
and the polynomials x i squared minus x
i
i and so the polynomial calculus the
nullchallenge systems can refute of
course exactly the same sets of
polynomials but a polynomial calculus
refutation can be substantially shorter
and have substantially smaller degree
due to the cancellation of of monomials
in intermediate steps so one sample
result here and a
rather strong result for the polynomial
calculus any polynomial calculus
refutation of the polynomials expressing
the negation of the pivotal principle
must have degree linear omega of n
so i want to conclude this talk with a
different subject of automatizability so
automatizability relates to
the hardness of proof search
which of course is a crucial issue for
satisfiability algorithms
we say that a proof system is
automatizable and we mean
typically in polynomial time if there's
a procedure
which given a formula fee as input
produces a t proof of proof in that
proof system
of fee within time the run time to
produce this t proof
is bounded by a polynomial of the size
of the shortest t
proof of fee if there is one so it
doesn't have to be polynomial run time
in the size of fee itself it just has to
run time in this
size of the shortest t proof of v
um surprisingly a related
concept is the notion of feasible
interpolation
which says that you can get feasibly
craig interpolants so if
a proof system t has feasible
interpolation if there's a polynomial
time procedure c
such that if p is a t proof of not
a p r and b q r then
c p r this is the results of the
polynomial time com
computation is a craig interpolant for a
of pr
and b of qr so rather nice result bonnay
and posse roz noted that if
t is automatizable then t has feasible
interpolation
um another nice result
is due to cryocheck and woodlock
the extended fraga proof system does not
have
feasible interpolation and thus is not
automatizable
unless the rsa encryption function
and the discrete logarithmic encryption
function can be inverted
in polynomial time
so one doesn't expect those can be
inverted in
polynomial time we suspect they're
secure and so
based on those hypo conjectures one
would conclude that
it's expected that the extent of vega
system is not automatizable
a similar result obtained by bonne
potassi raws shows that
phraga systems do not have feasible
interpolation and thus are not
automatizable
unless blum integers can be factored in
polynomial time
blah managers are products of two primes
each congruent to three mod four and
again this thought to be a hard
problem to invert or to factor such
factors such integers
and then finally there's been some very
striking recent results
just in the past couple years um
under the assumption that p is not equal
to np uh first of all at
serious and miller showed that if you
assume p not equal mp
it follows that resolution is not
automatizable
so there's no way to search for
polynomial length optimal resolution
refutations um unless p equals np
subsequent to that uh it was shown that
cutting planes is not automatizable
and also that the mill stellenzotz proof
system and the
polynomial calculus proof systems are
not automatizable
again in both cases under the assumption
that p is not equal to np
of course if p equals mp then every
system is automatizable you can
essentially uh ask bit by bit
does that for a shortest possible proof
um so these are somewhat negative
results although
not so bad because it's just saying we
although resolution
or cutting planes and northstone's lots
and localities
in some cases are strong systems it may
still be hard to find
these proofs a positive result though
is due to beam and potassium
that says that tree-like resolution is
auto-automatizable
in quasi-polynomial time so in other
words
we let s be the size of a shortest tree
like resolution refutation
and n is the number of variables then in
time approximately
n to the log s weak it's possible to
find
some tree-like resolution refutation
uh for resolution these methods give a
much
worse time bound of n to the square root
of
n log s
but these represent more or less the
state of the art for
automatizability that's the end of this
talk thank you very much
you